foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the top stories live from Sky News City
Studio
the chancellor summons the UK's biggest
lenders to Downing Street to discuss
soaring mortgage costs following
yesterday's shock interest rate rise
the surprise jump in retail sales the
Shoppers continue to spend in the face
of the cost of living crisis
drugs giant GSK reaches a settlement in
the U.S over claims of its former
Blockbuster hot burn drug Zantac caused
cancer
plus why female business owners are more
likely to turn a profit in their first
month of trading
foreign
[Music]
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt has summoned leaders of the UK's
Main High Street lenders to Downing
Street this morning to discuss the
mortgage crisis it follows yesterday's
interest rate rise from the bank of
England that has seen many borrowers
looking at another rise in their monthly
mortgage costs well joining me now is
Simon French managing Tourette's a chief
Economist and head of research at pamel
Gordon Simon welcome to you you thought
the bank should raise buying a quarter
of a point you think the Half Point
height was a mistake then it did reek a
little bit of panic
um lucky if you're being charitable you
would say they moved into Data
dependency a few months ago and the data
has come in hotter and therefore they
respond but Market expectations at the
start of the week were for 20 likelihood
of a 50 basis point hike that moved out
to 50 50 ahead of the vote personally I
think if you'd had the intellectual
confidence that the NPC look a bit short
of at the moment you would say
three-quarters of the impact of the
interest rate hikes we've ad which is
440 basis points 400 4.4 percent now 4.9
that's still to impact households and
businesses up and down the country and
we're making inflate we're making
monetary conditions for 18 months to two
years time if you're intellectually
confident to stand up there and go
that's the transmission that is why what
we've done will bring inflation down
you'd have done so unfortunately they're
not in that position that's pretty
damning words um why do you think
they're lacking this intellectual
confidence as you you call it well
forecasting errors both
um
you know unmissable as in you know there
was some stuff that was hiding in plain
sight I was quite critical in the
research note recently that they
misunderestimated the inflation impact
of growing migration for example which
has been going much faster than
government expected we had that data at
the back of the last year when they did
their reforcast in February they missed
that out I also felt they were too
pessimistic on the use of of household
savings to fuel consumer spending we've
got retail sales data out this morning
that was pretty strong again a story of
households showing pretty good
resilience so I've been critical of
those forecasting errors and then
there'll be some things which you know
nobody could have foreseen in terms of
the scale of that gas price move a
combination of those self-inflicted
errors and errors beyond their control I
mean they're human there aren't there's
no members of the monetary policy
committee although we lured them they
are human they are economists they are
prone to crisis of confidence and the
fact their models aren't working uh
means that that intellectual stance is
is quite difficult to take right now
they're also very clearly concerned
about the risk of over tightening and
causing a recession I mean who pill the
chief Economist did a speech on that
only the other day yes
um and therein lies the challenge if the
market is right and it's a big if and we
see UK base rates go to six percent by
the end of the year then added a
mortgage spread you know you start to
talk about seven seven and a half maybe
even eight percent for standard variable
rates around the UK that's a very very
difficult backdrop of the UK to avoid a
recession and therein lies the real
challenge for monetary conditions that
are having to tighten against what
initially and there are many critics of
the bank who say look this wasn't
generated by excess demand so you don't
have the right toolkit for dealing with
it the problem is second order affects
through wages through expectations of
the type that they're trying to lean in
with their blunt instrument they have
which is balance sheet reduction
interest rate increases are we now at a
point then where to get inflation back
to the two percent Target rate the bank
is going to have to engineer a recession
or can we still hit that Target without
there being one
well the recession definition two
successive quarters of negative growth
is uh it isn't really a definition at
all it's a it's a convention and it's
can they do it without a period of
pretty benign growth almost zero growth
and whether that fits this or technical
convention definition I think it's a
coin toss honestly at the moment but
there is no doubt I think that the scale
of monetary Titan they've had to do to
catch up with the inflationary picture
uh puts the UK on a slow growth path for
two to three years when we were rather
hoping that the the gas shock there was
the initial impulse for this would be
more of a one one and a half year impact
so you've just elongated that period
because of the kind of monetary timing
they're having to do to catch up with
expectations and and keep control of
core wage inflation obviously in the
Eurozone they're already in a technical
recession and the ECB has not yet raised
interest rates either as high or as
rapidly as the bank of England yeah they
don't have an 8.7 headline inflation
print there is the the difficulty and
why if you're data dependent and you
mentioned the Eurozone so around six six
percent inflation you look at the US and
look at what the Federal Reserve the the
central bank that sets monetary
conditions really for the whole world
and certainly sets the expectations what
do they do this month they said well
inflation has come down to four percent
still twice their target but they have
been able to say well given it has come
down a long way to close to their target
we can afford to pause and we may hike a
little bit later in the year but we want
to get more data they've brought
themselves Time by I mean just let's be
blunt a more assured managing of the
communications over the last 12 to 18
months they also have a lot more cheap
energy and access to it than we do in
the UK I guess absolutely if you
decompose the UK Consumer Price Index
the component part that is household
energy bills went up 120 percent since
the start of 2021 why was that well for
many viewers they will be saying well my
energy my average Energy bill went from
a thousand to two and a half thousand
compare that to the US the average
Energy bill went up just 25 percent at
the same period you're absolutely right
the energy composition enabled the US
economy to sort of see less less high
peak in CPI and come down faster now in
the last half hour we've had the latest
PMI purchasing managers inject survey
data figures for me I mean they're
pointing to the fact that the economy is
still growing in May can you extrapolate
that app for the full quarter yet is are
we looking at another quarter of growth
do you think here we are
um and
you know against comparable economies in
Europe that are shrinking the fact that
the UK seems likely now on the back of a
strong Services component which is 80 of
the UK economy uh printing a decent
expansionary picture versus a weak
manufacturing picture I still think it
sees us growth 0.1 0.2 for the quarter
nothing to hang out the bunting on but
at least avoids that rhetorical and
impact of a shrinking quarter which has
a pass-through to business confidence to
household confidence you know when uh
you know the data when business shows
such as this you know tell the story of
a negative quarter that has a an impact
on expectations on sentiment on business
investment intentions so I think the
fact that we've seen pmis today that on
aggregate suggest a Q2 expansion is
encouraging well we do Toronto the full
story here Simon good to see us ever
thank you my pleasure
but in the last couple of hours the
chancellor has been meeting lenders of
some of the big UK High Street Bank
mortgage lenders in Downing Street our
political correspondent Rob Powell is at
sir Downing Street Rob all the big guns
of uh been turning up I've seen Charlie
num from Lloyd's there and uh Debbie
Crosby from Nationwide and he uh read
out yet on what's been discussed
yeah seven or eight of them uh went in
just before eight o'clock that meeting
was due to start at 8am and then came
out about half an hour ago so an hour
and 20 now 30 meeting so far we don't
have any specific details um from the
treasury side we are expecting something
fairly soon
um though uh we tried to grab a word
with a few of the bosses as they came
out as well we didn't have much luck but
Charlie Nunn from Lloyds did give us a
broad overview of how things went have a
listen
come on
thank you so
productive discussion Charlie Nunn said
um there in terms of what they were
expected to talk about we know what it
wasn't is any talk about the government
providing direct support for to help
people pay their mortgages both the
government and labor as well both agree
that that would be counterproductive so
I think what it really is is sort of
updating on a mortgage Summit that
happened in December last year which was
about some of the flexibilities that
lenders already have to help people that
are struggling with their mortgage
repayments and how frequently they are
sort of seeking out and identifying
people that may be at risk of not being
able to meet their monthly repayments so
you're talking about things like
extending the mortgage term to lower the
monthly repayments mortgage holidays
potentially shifting onto interest only
mortgages as well so I think those are
the sorts of things that will have been
discussed today of course all of those
things though overall mean that a
borrower is paying more total interest
over the life of the mortgage so it's
not really dealing with a guess the
broader issue of an age now with higher
interest rates and I think that sort of
speaks to the broader political risk for
the government now of going into an
election year year next year and facing
the voters when mortgage rates are still
likely to be at levels they've not seen
been been at in a very very long time
and potentially coming off the back of a
recession caused by those increased
interest rates as well I think that's
why you're finding a lot of people on
the Tory side sort of searching around
for someone to blame if you like and a
lot of accusations directed towards
Andrew Bailey the bank of England
Governor crucially though the government
maintaining that the bank needs to do
what it can and do what it needs to do
to try and bring inflation back under
control okay thanks Rob
a bit of breaking news to uh bringing
that we've had in the last few moments
uh junior doctors in England will strike
for five days from the 13th of July in
what is thought to be the longest single
period of industrial action in the
history of the National Health Service
that's according to the British Medical
Association we'll have more on that
throughout the morning here on Sky News
yesterday's Bank of England rate rise
doesn't seem to have had much of an
effect on mortgage rates so far today
according to money facts the latest uh
average the latest data from them the
average two-year residential fixed
mortgage rate hasn't changed today
remains at
6.19 the average five-year fixed
residential mortgage rate is 5.83 that's
up ever so slightly from 5.82 yesterday
there are currently 4 444 Residential
Mortgage products available that is down
from
457 yesterday we're joining me now is
Paulie Gilbert she's marketing director
at the mortgage broker Tembo Polly
welcome to you a lot of incoming for you
over the last 24 hours I'm guessing
absolutely it's been uh the story of the
last year really that we've had this
turbulence in the market and uh
yesterday's announcement has been no
change but it's good to see the interest
rates have stayed fairly stable um from
lenders and that's really because most
vendors have already priced in
um some of these future rate Rises
and also worth pointing out I guess I
mean there are still nearly four and a
half thousand mortgage products out
there on the market I mean there is
still choice for those who are looking
to remortgage or indeed buy for the
first time
absolutely
um and I think that would be it's the
main message that we try and get across
to customers is the headlines at the
moment are really very scary and I think
it's causing a lot of
um upset and fear amongst homeowners and
first-time buyers that actually there
are a huge amount of products out there
um there are a number of different
options that can help people to keep
their monthly repayments low things like
interest-only mortgages extending the
term which can be done for a period of
time you don't have to stay on a on a
long mortgage term for the entire
duration of your mortgage it can just be
to see you through a period where
persons are really pinched on top of
that we've seen a really big increase in
the number of people looking at
guarantor mortgages in particular a
product called a joint borrower sole
proprietor mortgage and these are
increasingly popular amongst not only
first-time buyers who need a boost to
affordability but also people that are
remortgaging and actually just need some
support to be able to do that so there
are options out there I really would
encourage people to go and seek support
from experts obviously the money in
markets are not predicting any
reductions in interest rates until early
2025 now is that potentially going to
tempt some people into just going on a
floating rate for now and uh not risking
going in for longer than two years
interesting questions so we actually saw
that variable rates were incredibly
popular
um in the period after last Autumn they
haven't been quite so popular recently I
think people are shaken consumer
confidence has been shaken a bit by
increased rates
um we're seeing at the moment people
looking in for kind of two to five years
as the most popular option
um but let's see let's see what happens
Michael Gove obviously has been calling
for a greater take-up of 25 to 30 year
mortgages to get over this mortgage shot
coming it's worth pointing out there are
such products available on the market no
one seems to want to buy them
yeah I mean there was a there were a lot
of headlines a few years ago about
10-year mortgage terms
um these I think are
it's quite a scary thing to do to to
lock in for a product for 10 years
um particularly when the market is so
volatile you're obviously sacrificing
any potential reduction in costs in that
period as well as I suppose the upside
which is you could have more stability
so we continue to see that two and five
years are the most popular
that's interesting I mean the other
point worth making is that in the US
where these sort of mortgages are
commonplace they have organizations like
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac which we
don't have in this country that enable
the mortgage lenders to sort of uh you
know Market out some of their risk if
you like
well I think it's going to be really
interesting to see what comes out of
these meetings today
um my anticipation is going to be that
it will be mostly focused around
supporting borrowers who are in crisis
and so people that are unable to make
their monthly remortgage payments and it
is important to remember that A lender
has a legal obligation uh to a borrower
to look at a number of other options
before they move to anything like
repossession my feeling is we're going
to be looking at maybe things like
um reintroduction of mortgage payment
holidays that were very popular during
the pandemic but it'll be interesting
interesting to see if some of these more
interesting products that Michael Gove
has been talking about could come out of
these conversations
and what about the overall direction of
the housing market now probably I mean
are you anticipating big reductions in
house prices for the rest of this year
it feels like overall expectation is
it's going to be around 10
um I feel like a fool anytime I predict
anything now because the market has been
so volatile
um we largely so far this year have seen
quite a lot of resilience in the market
and interestingly we've still seen a lot
of
um a lot of inquiries from first-time
buyers who I think are really stuck
between a rock and a hard place in the
rents are going up astronomically and
they know that it's more financially
beneficial in the long run to own
so I think there's going to be an
interesting situation where house prices
will soften slightly and actually that
can be advantageous for first-time
buyers who might be chain free who are
chain free and have the ability to
negotiate a little bit more we're
definitely moving towards
um a buyer's market which will be a
welcome change for those looking to get
on the property ladder absolutely Paulie
we won't hold your forecast against you
good to see you today thank you
thanks
oh UK Shoppers continue to spend more
last month in the face of the cost of
living crisis with retail sales
unexpectedly Rising during May the
office for National statistics said that
retail sales volumes Rose by 0.3 percent
during the month that followed a 0.5
rise during April and was significantly
better than expected with the market
having expected a fall of 0.2 percent
well the ons cited strong sales for
online retailers selling outdoor related
goods and summer clothing which was
boosted by the warm weather in the
second half of the month there was also
a rise in Petra and Diesel sales during
the month although food store sales
volumes fell by half of one percent the
ons said this could partly have been due
to more spending instead on takeaways
and fast food because of the extra bank
holiday around the king's coronation
some other business news stories for you
now and the drugs giant GSK said this
morning it had reached a settlement in
the U.S over claims that its former
Blockbuster hot bun drug Zantac caused
cancer GSK which has always denied the
claim reached the settlement with
California resident James Gertz the case
was due to come to court next month in
what would have been the first test of
how the cancer allegations would fare
when heard by a jury well GSK said the
settlement reflected its desire to avoid
distraction related to protracted
litigation in this case is stressed and
not admitted any liability in the
settlement and would continue to
vigorously defend itself based on the
facts and the science in all other
Zantac cases
shares of Siemens energy fell by more
than 35 percent this morning after it
warned that problems with the quality of
turbines produced by Siemens gamessa arm
could last for years Siemens gomeza one
of Europe's biggest manufacturers of
wind turbines in the supply to many of
Europe's biggest wind power generators
admitted in January that it had
uncovered a batch of faulty components
that would cost it 500 million euros but
Siemens energy admitted this morning
that the problems ran deeper than
expected and could take longer than
expected to rectify it said the cost of
the business could not come in at more
than one billion euros
shares of Hotel Chocolat have fallen by
more than 15 today at one point after
the premium chocolate brand warned it
will make a loss this year and that
profits for next year will be lower than
expected the company which grows makes
and sells its own chocolate always said
this was going to be an intended to be a
transition year as it invests for future
growth but it added that cost saving
measures it had put in were taking
longer than expected to pay off it also
cited ongoing weakness in consumer
sentiment and continuing inflationary
pressures
British oil and gas producer Neptune
energy has agreed to a takeover by the
Italian oil major Annie malingit at 4.9
billion US Dollars including debt
Neptune was founded in 2015 with private
Equity backing by Sam Laidlaw the former
chief executive of centrica the parent
of British gas last year it produced an
average 135 000 barrels of oil
equivalent per day from fields in eight
countries including the UK Norway
Germany and the Netherlands it's Now 49
owned by the China Investment
corporation while the private Equity
firm's Carlisle group and CVC earned
30.6 and 20.4 percent respectively
thank you stocks in the Asia Pacific
region completed their worst week so far
this year overnight as investors focused
on Rising interest rates around the
world Shanghai could ignore the figure
there that was closed for a public
holiday but elsewhere there were
declines in Hong Kong Tokyo Singapore
Sydney and in Mumbai well in Europe
stocks are also going into the weekend
on a downbeat note here's the current
picture all of the main Continental
European markets in negative territory
right now here in London meanwhile it's
been a pretty similar story The ftse 100
is uh offer just over a tenth of one
percent right now all the mining stocks
Weighing on the index the biggest
percentage Faller is a cardo profit
takers have moved in there the stock
prices we reported this time yesterday
absolutely rocketed on some fairly well
I thought was some interesting bid
rumors let's put it that way uh they've
come off this morning while Dia Smith
the paper and packaging group it's off
another four percent following
yesterday's results not too many gainers
to mention in the footsie right now but
GSK which I mentioned a moment ago look
at that they're topping the ftse
leaderboard following Zantac Court
settlement overnight the shares some six
percent to the good right now outside
the ftse the frequency and microwave
technology specialist philtronic is
ahead by some seven percent on a trading
update but the subprime lender
non-standard Finance is off 43 after
scrapping a plant fundraising it's now
going to basically hand itself over to
creditors in a move that will wipe out
shareholders and that podcasting
specialist audio boom its shares have
fallen pretty dramatically this morning
as well currently off some 26 percent
following a profits warning on the
foreign exchange markets what's been
largely all about dollar strength this
morning as Traders look ahead to another
rate rise from the Federal Reserve
Sterling off by third or one percent
against the Greenback it is however up
nearly two-thirds of one percent against
the Euro The single currency meanwhile
is off nearly one percent against the
dollar as for the oil price well that
sold off yesterday amid concerns over
weakening demand the Battle of Brent
crude has continued falling today it
will currently set you back 72.98 a
barrel that is off just shy of one and a
half percent on the session or joining
me now is Bill dinning he's Chief
investment officer at waverton
Investment Management Bill good to see
you this morning and all of a sudden
everyone is looking really strongly at
interest rate Rises right around the
world and not just in the UK No in fact
yesterday almost sort of had a
coordinated feel about it the the
Norwegian Central Bank raised rates by
more than was expected just like the
bank of England did Switzerland raised
uh I think the the real thing I think to
watch here is is first of all I thought
the guilt Market reaction was
interesting yesterday yields at the long
end actually fell I think that might be
the market beginning to think as it was
also reflected in some of the inflation
swap markets so that a good way of one
of the ways of just figuring out what
the market thinks future inflation is
going to do that weekend yesterday so
the bank of England might well decide
that actually what they did yesterday is
is actually gone down okay and I
certainly think in terms of foreign
exchanges you were just highlighting the
critical thing really I think is to look
at the pound versus the Euro and the
pound is stronger again that today we
really weak data in Europe much worse
than ours uh well certainly worse than
ours and I think uh I think Sterling is
doing better against the euro is
interesting because there's a lot of
gloom and doom and Woe Is Us here but uh
from a from a Market's perspective I
think look at what currency look at what
Sterling's doing and look at what the
guild Mark is doing
and actually perhaps there's a ray of
Hope there
what about the Federal Reserve in
particular I mean we had a speech from
Jay Powell the day before yesterday
where he indicated that there were
further rate Rises coming down the line
do you think the us is going to Stave
off a recession
well we still think that the odds of a
recession are certainly over 50 just
because a lot of the indicators of the
economic cycle that have historically
been good at predicting a recession
appointing that way one of the ones that
I think is quite interesting is just
looking at corporate profits in the
national income accounts which sounds
terribly complicated but it's basically
just aggregating up the profits made by
all companies in the US so it's
obviously dominated by the big companies
that we all know but it also includes
all of the unlisted companies the
smaller businesses etc those profits
relative to U.S GDP are declining in
other words profitability is holding up
but it's it's declining as a percent of
GDP and that's quite often an early sign
that actually we are starting to see
some pressure on the profit margins and
if that's the case then I think uh I
think that could be another indicator
that perhaps the US economy is about to
sow more signs of slowing yes really
interesting point I mean it's
interesting so I'm in this bit there's
been a big debate in this country about
this so-called greed inflation I mean
there's nothing in any of the figures to
suggest that uh profit margins are being
enhanced at the moment let alone causing
inflation to rise yeah and I think
that's a tricky one because vast
majority of Industries remain extremely
competitive
uh there are one or two areas where
perhaps you've got some oligar Bliss
oligar ballistic of nearly nearly
Monopoly packages
uh where perhaps that's the case but I
think for the vast majority of
Industries I think most certainly a lot
of small businesses would say that
they're not in a position to to go for
greed inflation I think part of the
problem is that when you've got high
inflation the nominal World I.E the
nominal GDP or nominal profits are
generally are going up quite a lot
uh the only I often say that the only
people who live in the real world are
economists because they're focused on
real GDP and things but what matters is
actually nominal and there we have to
just be a bit careful because in a time
of higher inflation yes it may look like
there's some profit making going on but
actually if you look under the hood I
agree with you I'm not sure there's much
sign of that and if demand begins to
weaken that's not going to be possible
absolutely I mean and and on this demand
Story I mean the oil price is just
fascinating right now the Saudis are
obviously doing their level best to uh
put a floor under the price but demand
concerns seems to be outweighing just
about everything else in how it's
trading I think that's true and I think
it's also true of the broader commodity
complex if you look at the Industrial
Metals For example you know the
commodity complex is possibly starting
to sniff out there's a bit of weakness
and don't forget a lot of the those
Commodities are impacted significantly
about what's going on in China and the
Chinese are actually doing the reverse
of what's happening in the west so China
is actually starting to ease policy
because they've got a much weaker
economy than they expected six months
ago when they started to ease their
covid restrictions that that sort of
Chinese strength hasn't come through so
they're actually easing policy uh and I
think you know as far I think just
looking at the demand side in the west
though I I do think uh the commodity
complex is also sniffing out some of
that weakness I think there are some
interest rates Cuts around them Moldova
cut interest rates this week
we should we should we should get there
as soon as possible yeah so here it's
nice this time of year Phil good to see
you this morning thank you
still to come here on Ian King live
I'll be speaking to Winnie chew or
president of Dorset Hospitality
International about why female business
owners are more likely to turn a profit
in their first month of trading stay
with us
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent and this is where I grew
up we can reveal that the driver who hit
Harry Dunn is 42 year old am circulus
just met the president and I never
thought we'd get this far this is what
they're up against that the wind is the
really big problems it is back breaking
work and the smoke is thick
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really scary
we're terrified in this community I'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid hopefully this will be
the last wave
I never knew they would make it
amazing
seems tantalizingly close in this corner
of the UK Wales was the first to
introduce the plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Applause]
foreign
welcome back now female owned businesses
are more likely to turn a profit in
their first month of trading than those
founded by men and that's despite the
fact that more than one in three women
who start their own business do so with
less than one thousand pounds well
that's the chief finding of research
prepared to coincide with a nationwide
campaign to celebrate and encourage
female entrepreneurship joining me now
is Willie Chu she's the president of
Dorset Hospitality International Winnie
great to see you again I mean you're
running the family business now but you
started out with your own Burger chain
yes something like good memory okay yes
yes and um again I'm really I'm really
so few so privilege to come this time in
such such interesting times with
interest rate and all that but for sure
I'm a big supporter of woman women's in
business and um look I I was so lucky
yesterday because we were actually the
first to launch a woman's launch lab in
conjunction with the women's Enterprise
week so basically providing ladies
entrepreneur with a three-day boot camp
and um it's amazing I mean I had a panel
of Judges Mrs merty was also together
with me and um it's incredible we have
over hundreds of applicants and at the
end there were 12 contestants and they
lived three days on property and really
have boot camp training them on
different skills because I I think you
know as women also in business sometimes
we all have issues and knowing that and
we may have solutions to it but knowing
that we're not alone I think makes a
huge difference yes so tell me how
you're trading right I mean the last
time we caught up you were just opening
up here in the UK you're in 25 countries
now I think you've got more than 60
hotels yes yes I mean it must have been
pretty tough during the pandemic period
yes but again the motto of the business
is really invest in positive impact so
really we want to help whenever we can
so actually during covert time for us we
uh well thankfully our last three
covered years we were actually
profitable uh but it really for us it's
more like our core value building too
because it shines through so for example
in the hotels where you kindly visited
in the UK we turned into supporting NHS
and letting the medical
doctors and nurses stay with us and
places like Germany we became
vaccination centers like in Japan in
Hong Kong we became quarantined homes so
again really I think it's important
during tough times that we all
collaborate and help each other and like
what you said earlier about women's
Business starting small and all that one
thing I realized is that the difference
I mean I hope that that's not going to
be safe say I'm very sexist but
um because of my experience in VC as
well as PE that woman majority of time
when they start a business it's because
they had a problem themselves and they
want to find a solution to it so in fact
the winner yesterday Amelia
um and she had an accident when she was
young
um a teenage time and she then designed
a clutch that will actually that first
it looks more fashionable and second it
actually is some uh the the East is off
kind of all the strength here so it kind
of is more comfortable too and it's a
because she's living it every day so
hence she keeps on in improving and
improving so I think that is uh yeah
yeah I mean great businesses are often
formed out of uh adverse situations
aren't they yes I mean is is that true
of your business did you learn things
during the pandemic in terms of how you
were running the business that you've
been able to take forward into the
absolute World absolutely
um I think uh and I now industry anyway
and a lot of Industry now finding people
is absolutely the toughest so we believe
in upskilling So at the moment we are
bringing in more technology but not to
remove job but to upskill them to train
them to use a lot of times so now we use
check into robots and all that so to
upskill our colleagues it's important
and what we're also doing in the UK
we're working with a homeless and uh in
fact we train them to become in our
housekeeping but one of the requirements
of course is that we need to provide
accommodation so in fact we've now
converted a home and provide
accommodations for the homeless then
train them to to bring them to work in
the hotel wow and you are doing some
some other stuff with affordable housing
in this country yes yes affordable is
really in our heart we believe that when
the tide like when the tide rise all
boat Rises so we really want to help and
be inclusive
um so in fact we're lucky um that we
were doing one of the biggest projects
in the UK it's building six if I is
Consortium as is building sixteen
thousand homes in Manchester and it's
look it's over a 10-year project and we
are here for the long term and uh some
of our housing that we are launching in
kalihas really starts from about 200
plus pounds per square feet and in the
city center it's uh it's a below 500. so
even I mean of course a lot of rental is
going up so even I was just talking to
my colleagues yesterday uh in fact if
you buy now and um and you may still
have a positive carry because the yield
is about five six percent but of course
with the yesterday's interest rate it
will be more tough but I have High Hopes
good when it's lovely to catch up with
again after so long come see us again
soon thank you
still to come here on Ian King live what
the lack of women in engineering may be
down to what courses girls are choosing
at school stay with us
[Music]
foreign
welcome back well just now millions of
students will be gratefully coming to
the end of their GCSE and a-level exams
but the choice they've made in taking
the courses they have can have a big
impact on their future career well women
account for 48 of all occupations they
account for just 16 and a half percent
of Professional Engineers or my next
guest argues this is partly due to GCSE
and a level Choice don't you mean as Dr
hayatan silam chief executive of the
Queen Elizabeth prize for engineering
and the Royal Academy of engineering Dr
suleim good to see you this morning did
you see I see an a level choices really
have that much bearing on people's
future careers
well well they do in and actually thank
you very much for inviting me to talk
about this on International women and
Engineering day which is of course uh
really important from my perspective
because we do want to ensure that we
celebrate the women who are making
fantastic contributions as Engineers but
in the process also demonstrate to more
people that engineering is for everyone
it's a great career with high job
satisfaction Financial rewards you can
create the future you can improve lives
but as you say unfortunately not enough
women and girls are getting that message
um so yes I mean I think the world is
changing but at the moment your GCSE
choices will impact and what you can
then do for further study at a level or
in terms of technical routes and that
will then impact on which which degrees
or which Fe courses you can go on to
study and so uh we're changing in lots
of different ways so I think there is
some progress being made in terms of
those people who are educating Engineers
thinking maybe we don't need to be as
restrictive in terms of the subjects
that uh kind of you could you can have
in your um under your belt to become an
engineer so traditionally it's been very
focused on physics and maths as being
essential
um so there are there are lots of
universities now who are realizing that
by softening those requirements they can
they can tap into a different pool but
there's a long way to go and I think
that there is a just an ongoing
challenge to
um reshape people's perceptions I think
there's still a very narrow and outdated
view of what engineering is and who it's
for
well quite so but what about the
leadership in these industries the
science and engineering industry is
doing enough to to encourage gender
diversity in their businesses
I do think that in terms of business
there is now such a powerful
evidence-based supporting the business
benefits of diversity and inclusion from
Talent attraction retention motivation
through YouTube productivity health and
safety creativity that all serious
engineering businesses that I've come
across have understood that diversity is
necessary for achieving the business
success that they're seeking but I think
what hasn't happened consistently yet is
that's translated into really effective
approaches to attract people into
engineering and one of the challenges we
face is that I think over a long time
there's been a bit of fragmentation
there's lots of different people trying
to do different things at the same time
we're not making enough Collective
impact so we're really delighted that on
International women and Engineering day
the Queen Elizabeth Pride for
engineering which of course I'm Chief
execos
um which is the the world's leading
prize most prestigious prize for
engineers is partnering up with the
science museum to open a gallery in
London's iconic Science Museum which is
the first of its kind that really
focuses on showcasing who Engineers are
what they do and why it matters to all
of us and that's supported by a range of
Industry Partners as well and we need
people coming together around these
initiatives that cut through and reach
more people if we really want to move
the needle did we miss a chance with uh
with science in particular I mean if you
think back to the pandemic I mean the uh
the main covert vaccine produced at
Oxford and uh produced by AstraZeneca I
mean that was designed by Sarah Gilbert
and her team you know there was a strong
focus on women throughout that period
did we miss a trick there in not sort of
building on that success
yeah it's true we had some great great
Heroes and many of whom were women
during that period but actually one
thing that's really important to
recognize is that we often talk about
getting more women into stems so science
technology engineering and maths and in
fact the intake into stem is roughly
gender balanced because women are
overrepresented if you like in the
biosciences and subjects Ally to
medicine and they're really
underrepresented in engineering physics
and Computing and so we need to actually
hone in on what is the reason that we're
not doing so well in gender diversity on
the E but at our Gallery that's opening
today at the science museum that
um it's got a whole it features more
than 60 engineers and an amazing array
of exhibits that bring to life the
achievements of those engineers and one
of those for example is
um the Ventura CPAP breathing Aid it was
one of those breathing AIDs that was
used during those early days in covid
and one of the key people that we
feature there is called Becky Shipley
she's a UCL engineer she and her team
worked with hospitals they worked with
formula one team and together they
developed in a hundred hours a device
that went on to have a meaningful impact
on probably thousands of lives and so
that's that's the kind of thing we want
to get those stories better known
because sometimes we talk about science
but we don't shine a light and what is
it specifically that Engineers do and
without Engineers all that potential
that's created by science doesn't
actually result in products and services
and um infrastructure that we can all
benefit from
absolutely yeah well time at the science
museum is always well spent Dr Salem
good to see you this morning thank you
thank you very much
now regular viewers will remember that
two years ago we interviewed Susie ma
the entrepreneur behind the Tropic
skincare Beauty business about how she
navigated the pandemic well much has
happened since then not least the fact
that she's just bought full control of
the business from Lord sugar who snapped
up a 50 stake after she appeared on the
seventh series of his television program
but I've been speaking with Susie Moore
and began by asking why she'd bought out
Lord sugar
it's a buyout over a number of years but
I have bought him out outright but I'll
be paying him over a number of years and
it's something that I've been saving up
so it's a sole purchase on my side
there's no external investment or
external debt needed so it was a private
agreement between the two of us and was
there always I mean quite often you have
these sort of put in call option
agreements in in business was there an
agreement in advance that at some point
you could buy him out if you wanted to
no there wasn't such agreement in the
beginning when I first signed the
contract
um but obviously you know 12 years on
and the business has grown so much and
because Lord sugar and I are at very
different stages of Our Lives it just
made sense for us to part ways and go
our separate paths really what does it
mean for the business though I mean
obviously you're now the sole
shareholder does it Mark a change of
strategy at all
I think for me it changes my mindset you
know before as a 50 shareholder I'd have
to discuss any big things I wanted to do
with Lord sugar but now as the sole
owner
personally I feel more driven more
motivated than ever before and I know
that everything rests on my shoulders so
every decision that I make needs to be
really really good and
I just I feel more excited than I've
ever felt and I feel more optimistic and
positive about the future more than I've
ever felt so how are you trading right
now we're doing all right actually you
know considering everything that's going
on with the economy with the uncertainty
in the interest rate exchange rates
inflation and supply chain issues we're
doing all right we're tracking back to
kind of pre-pandemic growth and in terms
of our general sales and our consumer
spend there is still a huge amount of
demand for our products so
yeah we're doing well I'm very proud of
our team has that taken you by surprise
because obviously disposable incomes are
under real pressure right now the bank
of England raising interest rates again
does that at some point start to impact
on the business do you worry I
the products
that's right if you
if you call a day anymore if you can't
afford to treat yourself to a spa day
you may spend that money on some beauty
products to treat yourself at home or
some new makeup to make yourself look
and feel better so it's for us the
demand has been consistent and I think
because of the positioning of our
products in terms of the price range the
ethics and the quality we've not seen a
huge drop in consumer demand obviously a
lot of Cosmetics companies are now
moving into the ethical space and
putting a lot more marketing spend
behind it I mean L'Oreal being a very
good example do you worry about people
like that parking their tanks on your
lawn no
well you know for me the more Beauty
Brands that can move towards
inability the better it is for everybody
you know our purpose at Tropic is to
help create a healthy agreement a more
empowered world and we can't do that
alone I want BT brows to be more
sustainable to use less plastic to be
better for the planet how are you coping
with input inflation you still seeing it
yeah masses masses of inflation across
the board from just even like ever since
brexit actually just the changes in
interest rates and exchange rates and
also just things becoming more expensive
shipping things over from the Far East
from Europe we're facing challenges all
the time but at the same time we're
working a little bit smarter so
investing in Technologies the Machinery
that increases our efficiency which
means that we spend less time making
products and and it all helps our bottom
line have you been able to pass on the
full extent of the cost increases you've
seen to customers or are you having to
absorb some of the hit yourself yeah so
we've actually tried to absorb pretty
much all of the hit ourselves with the
cost of living crisis it's very
difficult to pass on the increase in
business costs to your consumer and
expect them just to take that on board
and be okay with it we did upgrade a
range of our products last year which
meant that we increased some of our
prices accordingly because the quality
improved but overall we've just absorbed
it and improved on efficiencies in-house
so that we can you know
continue to to run our business and what
does a typical customer look like these
days do you have many men buying the
products we are getting more men buying
our products now I think men are getting
into beauty products and skincare and
you know why not why wouldn't you look
after your skin it's it feels great but
the majority of our customer base tend
to be women they tend to be around the
kind of late 30s early 40s
tend to be mothers and tend to be women
who are health conscious and want what's
really good for their skin and their
body
a nice cheerful chat there with Susie
Moore well still to come here on Ian
King live the new tech helping people
with bladder weakness don't go away
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent and this is where I grew
up we can reveal that the driver who hit
Harry Dunn is 42 year old and sakulas
just met the president and I never
thought we'd get this far this is what
they're up against that the wind is the
really big problems it is back breaking
work and the smoke is thick
working well water levels are dropping
but no one knows what impact further
rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really scary
terrified in this community I'm told
that everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
um
tantalizingly close in this corner of
the UK Wales was the first to introduce
the plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Fly Emirates fly better
welcome back now tens machines are
famous across the land for providing
pain relief to women during childbirth
but the machines which deliver small
electrical pulses to the body via
electrodes placed on the skin to block
pain signals from being sent to the
brain are just one product made by
Surrey based tennis care the company is
now looking to help the millions of
people who suffer from bladder weakness
with a pelvic floor exercise or joining
me now as Neil writes he's managing
director of tenskennial good to see you
this morning um outline the problem for
me
well it's a bigger problem than what a
lot of people perceive it to be
um certainly the NHS has just put out a
report recently suggesting that it's as
many as 14 million people in the UK have
some form of bladder or bowel weakness
now that is a massive cost in cnhs so
the scale of it is big uh suggested
costs are around two billion to three
billion pounds worth of cost into the
NHS and we've developed a product a few
years ago as a pelvic floor exerciser
that actually is very effective pelvic
floor muscles respond well to that and
early intervention
um obviously mitigates some of the
longer term consequential costs of
trying to manage continents in a
hospital environment and without getting
too technical on me how does it work
well it's a probe that produces a small
gentle electrical stimulation that
causes the muscle to contract so if you
were lifting weights you'd lift weights
like that this is a contraction that
causes attraction and arrest period that
strengthens the pelvic floor muscles and
pelvic floor muscles respond really well
to that type of stimulation and how
frequently do you have to use the device
well 20 minutes a day for three weeks
for it's predominantly in women post
child birth but it can happen at any age
uh 20 minutes a week for three weeks if
you're suffering with what's known as
stress in constants that's why you're
coughing laughing sneezing and having an
embarrassing leakage so in that sense
and then urging constant square is an
urgency to go to the bathroom that might
take a little bit longer but again the
public floor muscles respond very well
to the treatment but the interesting
thing is that is this is actually a more
commonplace in men than in women well
actually in women it is very prevalent
uh in men it it occurs in men between
one and eight and one in nine men and
across the female population it is a
little bit more prevalent but it it
seems sometimes very often as an old
lady
thing and it's not it's very much across
it can affect uh people that actually do
quite sporty heavy weight lifters
um so it affects people that are active
as well it's it's not an age thing it's
not a demographic thing it's it's
physiologically we're all human and it
affects all bodies yeah and I mean it
does have other benefits uh pelvic floor
strength I mean it improves your sex
life if you're uh if that's well done
Ian absolutely right yes uh Stronger
pelvic floor muscle uh arrange you know
AIDS in sexuality and sexual function uh
so it's an important part of people's
life and the quality of life and it
affects people's quality of life because
it can be quite socially isolating you
know there'll be a lot of mums out there
or parents out there thinking is
children's sports day will I have to get
doing the egg and Spoon race now you
think that wouldn't be very threatening
but actually if that sort of jogging
along is going to cause some
embarrassment for you that is a fair and
that then leads to social isolation and
lots of other uh social uh problems and
psychological problems for the the
sufferer when in actual fact
you know we're often a solution that
tends care that is a solution to pop
that right and put that right quite
quickly and
you know there is an economic argument
for it as well in terms of not just the
longer term cost but the individuals you
go into any Supermarket uh lots of
containment and consonants pads there
that's not treating the issue that's a
regular cost of three or four or five
pounds a week
50 70 pounds by a public Sizer there's
lots of them out there it's not just
tense care
um you know it's a solution okay you
know good to see you this morning thanks
for joining me thanks very much
that's it from me I'm back on Monday
morning at 10 o'clock hope very much to
see you then in the meantime do stay
tuned after this short break it's Sam
Washington coming up with all the latest
on the junior doctor strike that has
just been announced in the last half
hour thanks for joining me today Cheerio
I know it was great thank you
[Music]
thank you